This is really funny video of Donald Trump
stepping in it again, but this time it's much
more innocuous.
It's not a crisis, it's just funny ignorance
and lack of context, but it actually relates
to a really serious issue related to one of
the most important issues we deal with as
as a, as a human species right now.
And that is climate change and pollution and
what we're doing to our countries.
So let's start with the clip and then talking
about, it will be even more illuminating after
we watch.
Make sure if you're watching on youtube that
you've hit the subscribe button to our channel
right now.
Trump was asked about the plastic straw controversy
and here's what he had to say.
I do think we have bigger problems in plastic
straws.
You know what's interesting about plastics
rise?
So you have a little straw, but what about
the plates, the rappers and everything else
in a much bigger and they're made of the same
material.
So, uh, the straws are interesting.
Everybody focuses on the structure.
There's a lot of other things to focus in,
but it's an interesting, interesting,
you know, the plates are usually not plastic
anymore.
Uh, so, so at any place that's worried about
plastic straws, it's probably paper plates,
but that's just Trump being out of touch.
He's probably still in the mindset of the
styrofoam food containers or something.
Who knows?
So there are like three interesting layers
here because this is just some dumb Trump
statement, but there's actually important
stuff here.
Trump under the belief that the straws are
plastic, but so are the plates and the cups
and everything is sort of saying like to really
deal with the plastic problem, you might have
to consider banning the plates and the utensils
and the cups and everything else because the
straws are really small.
He seems almost like open to the idea of banning
all plastic implements of this kind.
Like he's sort of saying banning only plastic
straws doesn't go far enough.
That's interesting because it doesn't sound
like it would be Donald Trump's politics.
Now, the backstory about the straws specifically
is that the reasons straws have gotten so
much attention is that everyday 500 million
of these plastic straws are used once and
they're thrown away because they're small.
People often don't even put them in trash
cans so that they contribute a lot to street
trash.
They get into waterways.
It's terrible for animals and they're not
recyclable anyway in most cases because of
their small size and they contain such little
plastic so they wreak havoc, so that part
makes sense.
That's why straws have become a thing.
There's been a movement to replace pet plastic
straws either by having people carry around
their own reusable metal straw to only give
customers straws when they've asked for them
instead of bringing them to everybody.
There are some alternative straws made of
like paper and bamboo and different things.
Every one I've tried is truly terrible.
Some coffee shops I go to have switched to
these for ice drinks and they just fall apart
into mush within 10 minutes.
So it's true that while the straws aren't
a lot of plastic, the things Trump has mentioning
often our paper and the large plastic items
are recyclable, so he just doesn't get why
people are even talking about straws.
Okay.
The really important message here is no matter
what we as individuals do in terms of consumer
choices like these, if we don't have big picture
wholesale change to pollution, resource usage
and energy usage, this stuff is a drop in
the bucket and that's why all of these consumer
movements are fine.
To the extent that they'll inform people,
hopefully they will impact human behavior
in some way.
That makes a small change, but Trump is sort
of getting at the idea that, listen, we're
not going to solve the crime at crisis climate
crisis that is with straws.
We need to be thinking way bigger.
The problem is Trump's against most of those
way bigger picture changes that need to be
made.
He's trying to revitalize an industry that
should be allowed to die, both because it's
failing and it's terrible for the environment.
The coal mining industry, just as one example,
Trump's reducing benefits or trying to reduce
financial benefits on electric cars.
He is completely right that if we have this
myopic focus on straws, we're missing the
bigger, bigger picture.
He just doesn't understand how we're missing
the big, bigger picture and he's against most
of the bigger picture changes that would need
to be made if we even want to look just at
like landfills, right?
If you just look at solid waste landfills,
it's obviously mostly not straws or even items
for eating food.
It's electronics products.
It's wood and large industrial plastics.
If we zoom out and look at the bigger picture,
uh, of solid waste beyond just consumer.
We're talking about industry and manufacturing
and construction that are generating just
untold amounts of waste, way bigger than straws.
We zoom out a little more and you realize
if we really want to fix this issue, we've
got to look at energy usage and then figure
out where is energy usage coming from.
And this dwarfs the straw issue.
So my point is not laugh at the plastic Straw
people or laugh at Trump for what he said.
A the plastic Straw people have a specific
cause.
It's a logical one.
Trump seems to be identifying that the straw
issue is not the be all end all the bring
your up growth on grocery bag movement.
It's a good movement.
But what we have to realize is that we have
to be thinking way, way bigger than these
retail level consumer choices, which are important.
But if we want to make real change happen,
and this is why lots of corporations end up
getting behind these movements.
We need to look at industry and we need to
look at transportation, big picture and we
need to look at energy.
This is why a lot of big corporations will
say, Oh yeah, we're, we're fully behind.
The plastic Straw thing going to paper are
only bringing straws when people ask for them,
they are appearing to be part of the solution.
While the real problem, which is the much
broader use of energy, uh, transportation,
fossil fuels that these huge corporations
contribute to, that gets ignored every time
the attention gets put on Straw.
So Trump is right.
Straws are not the solution, but he's against
most of the solutions that really would make
a big impact.